I would show you all the trades that I
took on my trade with eight account in
the span of 1 month
and brought me $60,000 in profit from
one account with a 78% win rate. I will
show you all these trades one by one and
also I will explain the strategy behind
them. And pay attention, there are many
tricky days in this month. I will make
sure to explain every single one of
them. So the people who will watch the
whole video are the people who will
benefit the most. That's why make sure
that you don't jump any section of this
video and to watch the whole thing. Now
let's jump into charts. We'll start by
the 1st of April. This is a quick recap
of my strategy. I only trade MNQ only
using the 5-minute time frame and only
on the New York session. And if you want
a full breakdown of my strategy, I will
leave a complete tutorial down below.
The first step of my strategy is
defining my bias, if I'm bearish or
bullish for the day. I do that with the
help of this Daxton trend indicator. You
can simply go to 10 in one different
moving average, simply copy these
settings. This is simply higher time
frame EMAs on my 5-minute chart. If the
price is especially over the 1-hour EMA
and these are pointing upwards, I'm only
looking for buys. If the price is under
the 1-hour EMA and pointing downwards,
I'm looking for shorts. This is simply
the first step. The pink box that you
see here is the New York session and
it's the only session that I trade. And
one mistake that some people are doing
that they buy under the 1-hour EMA or
they sell over the 1-hour EMA. We never
do that. Since we are bullish for this
day because we are over all the three
EMAs, we found the fair value gap here
inside this pullback right after market
open. This is where step three comes. If
we inverse this fair value gap that we
created right here, like we see here in
this candle, we go in, we place our stop
loss in a logical place. I will talk
about it later and we target simply the
past liquidity or two R. That depends
solely on market. You'll understand more
when you see future examples. This is a
quick summary of my strategy that
brought me these kind of numbers on
April. I moved my webcam to the upside,
so you can see the whole data. Let's
start by Wednesday, the 1st. So, as you
can see here, the price is over all the
three EMAs, especially the 1-hour, I
will be only looking for buys. Then,
market open with this candle right here
at 9:30. I waited because we didn't any
fair value gap here pre-market, and
these usually have also a lower
probability. And then, a fair value gap
was formed right here between these
three candles in this pullback against
our bias. Then, price broke through it,
that mean inverse it. I entered right
here after this candle closed, put my
stop loss under this inversion candle,
the fair value gap, and at the previous
candle. And since this liquidity gives
me less than two hours, like you see
here, 1.6 hours, I simply ignored it and
targeted two hours. As you can see here,
I made a little bit under 4K because my
risk was always 2K for this month. Now,
let's go to the 2nd of April.
As you can see here, market open
bearish, then we broke through all these
EMAs and my bias switched. Then, I
noticed that we inverse a fair value gap
that was formed pre-market. I entered
after this inversion candle closed,
placed my stop loss right under the
inversion candle, under this white EMA,
and under the previous candle, targeted
this previous liquidity, and got 3.2
hours. This is the 2nd of April. As you
can see here, 6.61. Many of you guys
asked me when you should take entries
based off pre-market FVG inversion, and
when you should take session FVG
inversion. There is absolutely no single
hard rule about it. I take pre-market
FVG inversion only when I believe we
will have a directional day. but for all
the remaining scenarios, I prefer
session FVG. And like I say always,
premarket FVG will always be a lower
probability trade. So, it's your choice
to either take it or leave it. Now,
let's go to the next day.
Here, as you can see, Friday the 3rd of
April, we had bank holidays.
And now, let's look at Monday, 6th of
April. You can clearly see that EMAs are
pointing up and the price is over then
after market open right here. And since
it's Monday, we simply ignore this
premarket FVG inversion right here. We
never take premarket inversions on
Monday because it's a very low
probability trade. So, here we formed
this fair value gap and this pullback.
After that, we got this inversion
candle. I entered, placed my stop loss
under the FVG, the inversion candle, and
under the previous candle, targeted
2R's, and I was stopped out immediately.
That's why never assume that this
strategy will always give you winning
trades or it doesn't have losing
streaks. Monday, the 6th,
I lost 2K. Now, let's go to the next
day.
Just between you and I, yeah, I
shouldn't have entered this day because
as you can see here, price keeps
breaking through all these three EMAs
again and again and again. That means
the market is basically flat and these
EMAs, as you can see, they are
overlapping. This is no trade day. And
also, don't think that I don't make
mistakes. I make mistakes every single
day. But on this one, I was a little bit
lucky. Let's zoom in. This day, I was
bearish because simply when market open,
we moved under the EMAs. Although I
already told you this was a no trade
day, we have this FVG that was formed
and it was inverted by this candle. I
entered, placed my stop loss over the
inversion candle, over the FVG, and over
the the candle, and targeted 2R's. Also,
one quick note, if you want to buy, you
need to find the inversion of bearish
fair value gap. If you want to sell, you
want to find an inversion of a bullish
fair value gap like we have here. This
day was the 7th of April, I made a
little bit over 4K. Now, to the next
day. Price here is over all the three
EMAs, we are looking to go long. We need
a bearish fair value gap. As you can see
here, we have one that was inversed by
this candle, entered, placed my stop
loss right here, and targeted a little
bit over 2R, targeting this previous
liquidity. This was the 8th of April,
also a little bit over 4K. Now, let's go
to the next day.
As you can see, price when market open
was over, especially the 1-hour EMA, I
will be bullish for the day. Then, I
waited for a bearish fair value gap to
be formed like you see here. We then
inversed it with this candle, entered
right here, placed my stop loss under a
FVG inversion candle, and at the
previous candle, and targeted yesterday
New York high. This trade gave me a
little bit over 3R. This was the 9th of
April.
As you can see here, a little bit under
6K. Now, to the next day.
Man, these videos are exhausting, but
you guys told me that you like the
previous one. Now, I will be quick with
this one. You can clearly see that we
are bullish right here. Then, after
market open, a bearish fair value gap
was created, inversed with this candle,
I entered, placed my stop loss right
here, and targeted 2R, but I was stopped
out. This was the 10th of April. As you
can see here, minus 2K. To the next one.
Here, after market open, price is over
all the three EMAs, I'm bullish. Now,
I'm waiting for a bearish fair value gap
to be created. We have one here,
inverted with this candle, placed my
stop loss under the inversion candle,
under the FVG, and under the swing low.
And to the left, I don't have any
previous liquidity to target. I targeted
2 R. This was the 13th of April, as you
can see, 4K. To be honest, this is a
textbook setup and it's so simple and
also shows the power of the strategy
when we have good market conditions. So,
in this day, we are clearly bullish. We
are waiting for a bearish fair value gap
to be formed. We have one here, inverted
with this candle, entered, placed my
stop loss under FVG, inversion candle,
and swing low, and targeted 2 R. This
was the 14th of April, as you can see,
4K. Now, to the next one.
As you can see, we are clearly bullish.
We are looking for bearish fair value
gap. We created one, then we inverted
with this candle, entered, placed my
stop loss right below the FVG, and
targeted 2 R. This was the 15th of
April, 4.2K. Now, to the next one.
In this day, we are bullish, had market
open here, created a bearish fair value
gap, broke it, entered, stop loss here,
targeted London high, 2.2 R, 16th of
April, 4K. To the next day.
We are clearly bullish. We have a
bearish fair value gap. Price broke it
with this candle, entered here, targeted
2 R. This was the 17th of April, also
4K. To the next day.
We are clearly bullish because we are
still over the 1-hour EM A. We switch
bias only when we close under I kept
drawing FVGs in this pullback, then we
inverse the latest one. I entered,
placed my stop loss here. I was
targeting this liquidity, but market
closed right here, and I always close my
positions before market close. I got 2 R
from this trade. This was Monday, 20th
of April, a little bit over 4K. Have you
seen how beautiful this winning streak
is? Now, let's go to the next day.
I was bullish when market opened. Then,
we inverse this bearish fair value gap
with this candle, entered, placed my
stop loss at this level, then got
stopped out. This is Tuesday, 21st of
April. I lost 2K. And if you need help
with the strategy in terms of execution
or your psychology, and you need to be
at least six figures funded and to be
able to pull payouts from prop firms
every month, I work only with a limited
number of people 101. If you are willing
to put the work and listen to everything
I tell you, apply in the first link in
the description down below to book a
call with me to see if you are the right
fit and to make sure that I don't waste
your time and you don't waste mine.
Let's jump to the next one.
As you can see, here we are clearly
bullish. We have a bearish fair value
gap. We inverted with this candle. I
entered, placed my stop loss at this
level, and targeted 2R. This was
Wednesday, the 22nd of April. I made a
little bit over 4K. I just can't believe
that I'm sharing this strategy with you
for free. That's why make sure to
subscribe, drop a like, and leave all
your questions in the comments down
below. I make sure to answer every
single one of them. Let's jump to the
next day.
I was clearly bullish when market
opened. I used a pre-market fair value
gap, as you can see, right here. My
entry was after this candle ended. I
targeted this previous liquidity and put
my stop loss under the FVG and inversion
candle, and I was stopped out. This was
Thursday, the 23rd of April. I lost 2K.
And to be honest, I should have added
another trade here. As you can see, we
have a bearish fair value gap that was
created in session. That's why it's a
higher probability trade. I should have
entered right here, put my stop loss at
this level, and targeted previous
liquidity. This was going to be a
winning trade. But to be completely
transparent with you, I didn't enter
this trade because 95% of the time I
only take one trade per day and I didn't
want to risk with this one. Let's go to
the next day.
So, in this day we are clearly bullish.
Then we formed the bearish fair value
gap, got inversed with this candle. I
entered, placed my stop loss under the
inversion candle, under the FVG, and at
the previous candle, and targeted this
previous liquidity. This was a 2.1R
trade on Friday, the 24th of April. I
made a little over 4K. I hope that this
video answers a lot of your questions
regarding the FVGs, the stop loss
placement, execution, and everything.
Let's jump to the next one.
In this day we were clearly bullish, but
we didn't have any bearish fair value
gap that was created here at this
pullback. We only had one created right
here and the inversion happened 45
minutes from the market closure. Plus,
we can clearly see here that volume
started to die. That's why I didn't
enter this day. That was Monday, 27th of
April. As you can see here, I took no
trade. Now, let's check the next day. As
you can see, we are clearly bearish in
this day. So, we are waiting for a
bullish fair value gap in a pullback to
be inversed. That happened at this
candle. I entered, placed my stop loss
at this level, and targeted previous
liquidity. This trade had give me 2.6R
as you can see. I made a little bit over
5K. Now, on to the next one.
This is a very good example. As you can
see, the EMAs here are too close to each
other. The price keeps going through
them all. That's why I decided this day
to not take a trade at all cuz my bias
is simply not clear at all. This was
Wednesday, the 29th of April. As you can
see here, I took no trade. Now, let's
jump to the last trade.
In this day, you can see that we are
clearly bullish. Although we did go
through the EMAs multiple of times, but
they are not so close to each other like
you see here. And if we zoom out, you
can clearly see that they are pointing
upwards. I waited for the price to be
over the EMAs and to print a fair value
gap. It got inversed by this candle. I
entered, placed my stop loss right below
the FVG, the inversion candle, and
previous candle, and also at the 1-hour
EMA, and targeted this previous
liquidity. This trade gave me 2R as you
can see here. I made 4K. I hope this
video taught you more about my system
and how you can master it. And if you
have any questions, just make sure that
you leave them down below. Make sure to
like, subscribe, and let me know what
you need to see in my next videos. Let's
meet on the next one.